- [Narrator] This shipment
of giant turbine blades
is part of a wind farm project
being constructed on the Shetland Islands,
a tiny archipelago,
more than a hundred miles
north of Scotland in the UK.
Its builders say the farm
will be the country's
most productive onshore wind farm
when it's finished in 2024.
Yet this remote community in the North Sea
roughly half the size of Rhode Island,
is also surrounded by
some of Western Europe's
largest offshore oil fields.
The flow of oil money
over the past 50 years
has brought jobs and
prosperity to the people there
but that flow could soon
be more of a trickle.
Here's what's at stake
as the islands overhaul their economy
from relying on fossil
fuels to clean energy
and how that plays into a
broader energy transition
taking place beyond this
small corner of the North Sea.
The North Sea around
Britain is running dry.
After about 45 billion barrels of oil
have been produced here
over the last 50 years
roughly 6 billion barrels are left
according to the North
Sea Transition Authority,
an industry regulator.
That is not even enough
to fuel the United States for one year.
Near Shetland, oil rigs are being scrapped
but the islands have an abundance
of another energy source,
wind, so a shift is underway.
The Shetland Islands
are one of the windiest places in the UK,
so windy in fact, that
turbines at the four wind farms
currently on Shetland must be stopped
at certain times of the day
to prevent the local grid
from being overloaded.
- Shetland's got a really
strong wind resource
where it sits in the very tip of Scotland.
It's got very, very strong winds
that then means you're getting high energy
from your wind farms.
It's also got a lot of infrastructure
that's been catered to oil and
gas and a lot of expertise.
- [Narrator] More windmills are on the way
along with a connection to
the national electricity grid.
That could enable all
households in Shetland
plus half a million UK
homes to be powered by wind
as soon as construction
of the Viking Energy
Wind Farm is completed,
according to the company
behind the project.
This shift, though, is not
without challenges for Shetland
both onshore and offshore.
Local fishers are worried about turbines
and undersea cables
disrupting fishing waters
around Shetland.
- If they cordon off an
area and put in windmills,
then it's unfishable to us
so it's basically taken
away our livelihood.
It's like saying a farmer,
"Right, I'm gonna take half
your field and fence it off.
You can't put your sheep or
cows there, you can't use it."
- [Narrator] Offshore wind
farm developers have said
that there is an ongoing
engagement with the islands.
- So there's two key challenges
that the offshore wind
industry is facing today
and that is ramping up to
meet government targets
that are set in place for net zero.
It takes roughly, you know, five years
to build your project, to
get through permitting stages
and actually bring that project online.
So if you're wanting to
meet that 2030 target
you need to be planning these project now.
And then also cost challenges
where we're looking at inflation
and the increasing cost
of capital expenditure.
- [Narrator] Keeping one
hand on the oil drill then
can seem quite appealing.
And amid protests by climate activists
in July Britain committed to granting
hundreds of new licenses
for oil and gas extraction.
- Well, it's great to be in Scotland
to strengthen our energy security
with more licenses for the North Sea,
but also speed us on our way to net zero
with carbon capture and storage.
- It's no secret that
the margins are lower
in offshore wind than
they are in oil and gas.
And that does pose a problem
for these kind of rural communities
that are very reliant on
established oil and gas hubs.
- [Narrator] But worldwide
winds are changing.
The US aims to have 30
gigawatts of wind power
installed in its seas
by the end of the decade
enough to power roughly all of Texas.
In Europe, the number of offshore turbines
is set to increase by nearly
400% over the same period.
The Shetland Islands are well placed
to help meet that growing demand.
But as a broader energy
transition gears up
and seas become more crowded,
the next challenge will be
for new and old industries
to find a way to coexist.
(gentle music)